lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
una prueba visual del por qué la
derivada con respecto a x del coseno de
x es igual al menos seno de x y vamos a
pasar este argumento en una prueba
anterior que hicimos y que decía que la
derivada con respecto a x del seno de x
es el coseno de x así que ojo voy a
suponer que sabemos esto así que te
encargo que veas ese vídeo donde
demuestra que esta derivada del seno de
x es el coseno de x y con ella vamos a
probar de una manera visual que en
efecto la derivada con respecto x del
coseno de x es el menos seno de x y
bueno por acá arriba tenemos la función
seno en color rojo y la función coseno
en color azul y ojo estamos suponiendo
que esta curva de azul muestra la
derivada de la función seno para
cualquier valor de x es decir nos
muestra la pendiente de la recta
tangente
esa intuición nasales de los vídeos
pasados y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
trasladar estas dos gráficas hacia la
izquierda por pi entre dos si vamos a
trasladar esta gráfica de rojo a la
izquierda por pi entre dos y vamos a
hacer lo mismo para la gráfica de azul
la vamos a trasladar pi medios hacia la
izquierda entonces que voy a obtener
bueno la gráfica de azul ahora se ve
como este de aquí y si teníamos la
función coseno de x entonces podemos
decir que esta es la gráfica del coseno
de x + pri medios ok si tenemos la
gráfica de azul es decir al coseno de x
lo estamos desplazando pin medios a la
izquierda y me quedo con el coseno de x
+ pri medios y siguiendo la misma lógica
esta es la gráfica de la función a seno
de x + pri medios ahora bien nuestro
argumento va a ser que estas dos
gráficas solamente las trasladamos a la
izquierda por medios por lo tanto sigue
que la derivada de la gráfica de rojo es
la gráfica de azul ojo por lo tanto
ahora podemos escribir que la derivada
del seno de x + pri medios esta derivada
va a ser igual al coseno de x + pri
medios alcor seno de x + pri medios
ahora aquí es equivalente el seno de x +
pri medios bueno observa esto es lo
mismo que el coste no de x y lo puedes
ver aquí observa la gráfica de rojo de
aquí abajo y puedes ver que es
exactamente lo mismo que la gráfica de
azul de arriba y cuánto es el coseno de
x + pri medios bueno una vez más por
nuestras identidades trigonométricas
puedes saber que esto es lo mismo que el
menos seno de x usa las identidades
trigonométricas así que aquí lo tienes
el argumento completamente visual de que
se comenzamos con este dato y
trasladamos las
gráficas hacia la izquierda por medios
entonces es cierto que la derivada con
respecto a x del seno de x + pri medios
es igual al coseno de x + pri medios y
eso es exactamente lo mismo que lo que
tenemos acá abajo así que ahora puedes
sentirte bastante bien gracias a que
probamos esto en otro vídeo ya podemos
decir que tenemos un argumento visual
muy fuerte para la derivada del coseno
de x nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo